Uh, I got a quarterback option with elite sauce
Elite sauce? That's me. I'm elite
Here you go
That was really fast. You must be exhausted
Yeah, I'm saving up to go back to college
Hey Joe, come sit with us
We were just discussing six-yard checkdowns
Listen guys, no offense, but
I'm a little bit more than a game manager
I'm going to go sit over there
Uh, come on!
Hi, I'd like to apply for an Elite QB Club Card
Ok great. Just a couple questions to see if you qualify
So, have you started in any Super Bowls?
Yes
And did you win?
Yep. And I was also an MVP so
And was that league or
Super Bowl
Uh Ok
I was also 2008 Rookie of the Year
That's great, that's awesome
Alright, so have you ever thrown
for more than 4,000 yards in a season?
I have
And how many times?
Once
One, one one one
Oh wow hey, the rest of your stats just popped up right here
Technology, right? Ha ha
Nice 2012 season
Fantasy ownership 14 percent. Yikes!
Hey, you know what? Let's just hit submit
Oh sorry. Not elite